i am ashamed to admit this
but um i only just recently found out
that welsh is a whole language
not just an accent
i really didn't know that
and here we are that shows the bigotry
of the rest of the world and
it's not going to surprise you it's
mainly because of the english
yeah
english english english the english did
a lot of horrible things to suppress the
welsh language throughout history
but
actively like yeah similar similar to um
the way uh like american schools did
right with like native american cultures
like just kind of blocking the use of
language in schools and stuff like there
was you weren't allowed to use welsh
kids weren't allowed to use their native
language i'm not sure i i've never i've
never heard that before i don't doubt
that that's possible but i'm not about
the america i don't yeah yeah if i'm
barking up the wrong tree fair play i
don't know the history but i know it was
definitely a thing in wales i would just
say it's been it's actually it's
actually always been a point of
contention in the us that there's no
official english is not official state
language we have no
uh
declared english yeah
decree i mean like we there is an actual
in like american standard english that
would be you know would have dictionary
delineations between the british
versions and australian versions and
blah blah the point is the government
does not officially endorse like we are
a this is one of those what's
contentious about that because the
racists i'm gonna guess racist well i
won't i won't make that leap but there
are like
definitely typically like conservative
elements that say you know you come here
you learn the language and there's also
a lot of immigrants who agree with that
they say i came here i got on my feet
and part of that like i take pride in
the fact that i came here didn't speak
english now i speak english but there's
also the aspect of being such a super
pluralistic society like in california
huge swaths of things are in both
english and spanish because they realize
huge amounts of people that live in
southern california so do i i've always
thought that was cool and it's like our
our sort of half-assed little taste of
what it's like for europeans who live
with languages in all directions which i
always envied
uh but um but uh yeah that is i do think
it is a it is a point in the us's favor
that it's always been
um multiple there's always yeah and
there's always been an uphill battle at
the idea of there being like a
governmentally declared you must
learning like you must pass a test to
show english proficiency in order to do
x or y here which we've never had wait
so you don't have to do that if you go
for citizenship
i don't think so i have no idea what
that test is that i don't either i
wouldn't be surprised if there are not
like spanish language editions of the
citizenship test so like it's
like sort of
spanish or something
it's pretty no that would be wrong it
would be it would be 38 percent latina
latino
well yeah yeah but i probably [ __ ]
that entire statistic up i
yeah
i don't know what what i'd be curious
about number one is really interesting
anyway i didn't realize this until
recently
there's an inherent kind of flaw in the
way that um
so uh ethnicity in the census in america
is basically
um any anyone who has a parent who isn't
white
is classified as not white so you have
an inc there's often the census data
kind of basically inflates uh would that
not be correct perception of
well that's the question right what even
defines white i don't i mean this one
defines why that's an arbitrary line but
also it means that all a lot of um
a lot of people who would identify
as white or would identify as of mixed
heritage are not kind of in other
countries the census kind of allows for
folks to self-identify mixed interesting
interesting but also in america you're
kind of essentially locked in say again
sorry yeah well you're saying yeah like
the the mixture being the nuance like if
you're biracial uh
you know you may not
you may not identify you might identify
as i'm biracial i'm not
sure i'm not right white or black even
if i'm even if i'm so-called white
passing or whatever an american census
data i don't believe you can define
yourself that way in terms of those
which has both like i i remember uh
that's what's tricky from uh tiger woods
point of view like he
he belonged to whichever race it was
convenient at the time
when he was cheating he was black
but when he wasn't he was
you know when when he was america's
sweetheart he was he was he was uh
diverse like they just like really pick
and choose
which he was based on what was this is
also the the very insidious side of this
is where all the like jim crow history
is of the whole kind of purity test
where someone could be like they had
like one black grandparent like nine
generations back and it's enough
for the like under the jim crow laws it
was there was the whole one drop of
blood is all you need to sort of qualify
as being
uh subject to those prejudices and those
sort of institutionalized
blog but that's why it may even be this
i have no idea if this is accurate but
it may even be that part of the reason
why the census data is
slightly
um unnuanced is as an attempt to move
away from those like
that notion of
you know are you purely this or that how
do we prove it kind of because there's a
real dark history attached to that you
know you're black but are you really
black or are you really white like that
they're still all very boring it comes
of that you know yeah and still a lot of
very boring statistics podcasts and
stuff and i think that's the the nuance
is always the tricky thing because yeah
it's always or often often we'll say
often done with the best intentions but
you can lead to these really interesting
kind of unforeseen circle consequences
though the the killing of the welsh
language was 100 a deliberate
plot by the english government though
that's that's that was absolutely again
i had no intentional thing i've heard it
spoken and it's really wild
awesome language very different it's
it's like this tolkien
sort of like very ancient sounding
language it doesn't work
i remember welsh yes
very little welsh so i don't it's not
like yeah they put it on your own you
didn't see that somebody put like was i
don't look at my wikipedia very often
they tweeted it at us uh
when that episode came out
with the mike bithell lore updates yeah
yeah it is really cool that's the welsh
accent is one of my favorite accents in
the world
i love it big fan um glad we covered all
of these topics on play watch listen
this is why everybody tunes it yes the
gaming podcast the people have come to
expect
um but related i did intend to talk
about ghostbusters which i love that if
my arm disappears because i don't have
my green screen up because i have a dev
kit in the background and you're not
supposed to show them on camera um so
does it validate that to talk about it
then
what no no it's specifically focused oh
yeah you're allowed to mention that you
have one yeah you just got the same i
think i've got the same contract yeah
yeah yeah um oh very odd
yeah they just don't want people to see
what they look like i guess and yeah so
so i put my ghostbusters background up
but it keeps making my arm disappear it
looks like this ghost is eating me and i
think it's a feature not a bug is that
is
i am made of metal um yeah he's a
muncher is what he's called it's a
muncher okay he is a muncher he's like
the slimer species pretty much yeah uh
played by [ __ ] i forgot the actor's name
but uh his face just suits it so well um
so austin i saw this i know you haven't
seen it yet right mike
i've not yet known uh audience we're
talking about ghostbusters afterlife
i should we put a spoiler uh warning and
give more than eight seconds of of we
can talk about it at length but like i
feel like we can not do spoilers
initially and then we can let's not do
spoilers because i've not seen it yet oh
that's also gonna watch this on the
plane at some point yeah i thought you i
thought that was your whole i thought
you didn't care about
that i'm not actually you know what i'm
not i honestly i reckon i could make
given what i've seen from trailers and
stuff i think i could probably make a
good guess at 80 percent of what you
could probably guess the entire movie
yeah i think i know i think i could even
guess like the heartfelt final scene of
this movie from the trailer so i think
all of it josh
is the answer
i don't know that's gonna be my guess
because he plays every single character
that looks like that it's brilliant
um i
really enjoyed the movie i was like this
is great what a fun time
saw reviews
did you know it's getting like fives and
sixes
i saw that it was getting
panned and i i i hate it i had no i
wouldn't what's the main criticism
obviously not outraged i don't care i'm
like my attitude is whatever [ __ ] you
want review whatever you want um
but i didn't expect it because when i
was watching it
i was just having such a good time that
like i was like this is great like what
a fun film i had an excellent time
watching this it was funny i liked the
characters it's certainly like you could
argue it you only liked it because of
nostalgia but i only watched
ghostbusters for the first time last
year so
i
well and likewise i actually i've
developed such an allergy
to
banking on nostalgia as a way to win
over the audience that i actually i
actually will have the opposite reaction
if if if a thing feels like
it is predic if my enjoyment of it is
predicated on it invoking nostalgia of
liking something else it will make me
hate it uh that's
part of why i hated the last
ghostbusters the melissa mccarthy
christian wig it felt like they were
trying to rehash
the the the movie in the in a sort of
lazy way and it was such a shame because
they squandered the outrageous talent of
their cast in like such a like in a such
a fool's errand kind of way it was such
a such a shame i went into that movie so
excited to love it as a super hardcore
ghostbusters fan
and it felt like the only things to like
about it were the things that were sort
of dependent on having this sort of
mindless nostalgia this film
is
yes there are it does have um some
elements of nostalgia um but it doesn't
feel like it's
trying to
win me over by doing the south park
member berries play of you know hey hey
remember remember the ecto one remember
slimer remember proton packs
a little bit
see it i to me it doesn't do that
because it's
to the extent that it does it's actually
organically part of the story the whole
point is no that's this is a thing that
was forgotten and now you're it's there
they are
discovering a connection to a past they
had no idea of to me there's such the
movie is full of interesting choices
like the first two but especially the
first one you are right that as the kids
are discovering things that existed
before that in theory you could argue
with the member berries say hey look at
the car
they're excited about it not because of
who it belonged to beforehand but
because of what it does for them at that
point in time which means that it
doesn't feel like the the sole purpose
of them being excited to see this
vehicle is nostalgia it's literally
useful to them
um tremendously not just not just and
not just that they don't even appreciate
it that's like their arc that's the
whole point they don't even realize that
it's special until they realize it uh
to them it's like who's this junk by
some guy we never met like it's that
that was such a smart choice and the the
other thing that i love about it is that
the first two
are
namely the first one is like a
quintessential new york film new york is
a character in the movie for sure i mean
even in the second one culminating in
the
the you know rescuer the savior of the
day is literally the the statue of
liberty like they they make a whole
point of new york the second one's plot
is predicated on the bad vibes of new
yorkers manifesting as literal slime and
the only thing is if they can appeal to
that elusive good side of new yorkers
and what i love about this one is they
go okay
set it out in the country like how do we
move as far away from that as possible
as a way to say you know what's the real
heart what's really what really matters
at the at the soul of this because if
this is another like city movie we start
re hashing all those archetypes it's
just going to get lost in the nostalgia
and to me it felt like it very
purposefully built a relationship in a
reactionary in an interesting way to the
original
there's so many things that i that i
loved about this movie that i i it's not
perfect like there were a few little
things that i would be like i wouldn't
have done that necessarily and blah blah
blah but there were some things some
some jokes that didn't land for me uh if
i were to guess what the criticism
was from reviews and again i was still
so surprised because i thought it was
really good i really would have thought
everyone liked it um
i it
the
the big bad guy plot
may as well be a rehash
it like you could fair point that that
yeah i can make no difference it is the
same concept with some of the same
enemies but like what do i get
i i agree that is one of my quibbles
i feel like they almost pulled off
they almost pulled off a way to kind of
like make it
feel
inevitably related to the first in that
regard yeah saying this in intentionally
vague ways
but i appreciate it me and the audience
are very grateful yeah but it it it i i
agree
that could have gone either way uh i i
don't i didn't love that about it but i
didn't hate it because it was it was
doing well otherwise but i i fair point
to that yeah that they they do
um
they did a little bit force awakens
that yeah aspect of it i think they did
can i ask a question
you may
it is interesting and i've not seen it i
didn't get a chance to weigh in on if he
should be allowed to do this but okay
austin do you think that mike should be
allowed to ask a question i'm just not
sure if they're close to the show i'm
going to say i'm not sure if we're a
democracy
austin i would like to hear if you would
like my the king says i may do this
austin all right all right i i'm curious
go ahead mike
this this had better be an interesting
question that kicks off 10 minutes more
conversations
yeah what why why is slimer green
no my question is um from the trailers
and stuff from everything i've seen of
it it does feel
like weirdly non-cynical in terms of
like its humor it seems very kind of um
warm and fuzzy and
nostalgia is a part of that but like
just more generally it just seems like
it's that kind of upbeat movie um i'm
sure there's some some dots in there my
question like thematically does it feel
to me watching the trailer it feels like
a kind of jump from like alien to aliens
where it's like yeah we're using the
same iconography the same characters but
like this is a completely different tone
of film does this feel like that kind of
jump or does it feel no similar to
what's before here's what they did
yeah the first film tonally
is bill murray
it's like cynical new york uh everything
sucks working in class
what that dude is about evil government
his sense of humor you get it the second
film is paul rudd
so they took the what you think of these
two humans and they just
blew up paul rudd so the humor is paul
rudd's humor like across the board which
feels like completely like different to
me
very he's very ant-man it is different
he's like it's not super different but
it's like he's like a giddy like
happy-go-lucky type and i feel like so
are all of the kids who are now our
heroes and one thing that i really like
about them using children to replace the
uh ghostbusters in theory um is
those yeah i'm sure the ghostbusters
aren't in this at all those four it's
not a key scene where they say those
four men
uh children
and you can't do that twice
i think that's kind of like what the
last movie which i didn't hate for the
record a lot of people hate the old
female movie i didn't hate that movie i
was fine with it i thought it was fine
um solid piece of fine it was a
mcdonald's happy meal kind of fun yeah
um but it's hard to do that twice with
adults because they're all really
childish they're kind of dumb you can't
do it twice so then having it be kids
who are learning and making these
mistakes is a really good way
to make that not just feel weird um so
yeah i don't think it's alien to aliens
i don't think it's that different it's
still alien it's just you put paul rudd
in it
here's my here's uh
here's my version of that i'd largely
agree although i think paul rudd i
thought he would be
a bigger focal point of the movie yeah
i'm just saying i think that he is a
good person to explain us it's like
you're a yardstick yeah exactly
thermometer yeah
but the thing is
when it was first like
the backstory being that jason reitman
is the director the son of the of ivan
reitman who directed the first two films
and is like a legendary comedy director
in his own right
though
though with these film with like the
ghostbusters is kind of stupid right did
thank you for smoking he did one of my
favorite films ever made which is up in
the air with george clooney um and the
thing is his movies are all like i
remember a friend of mine when it was
announced jason reitman is making a
ghostbusters sequel that's like
you know unlike the
the the the kristen wiig melissa
mccarthy one like this is a direct
sequel uh it's not a reboot um
set you know 30 years later basically
into in modern times and
um and a friend of mine was like jason
reitman doesn't make funny movies though
like the the ghostbusters is at heart
fundamentally comedy and jason reitman
makes like
the sundancy dramedy introspective they
have their fun
films he makes films that are listeners
watch and go oh yes that's very clever i
see what you did there sorry yeah i
don't think about me watching a
shakespeare comedy i'm laughing
but i'm also no one believes me that i'm
finding it funny like i get it
yeah it's sort of his movie and like to
me up in the air is actually like a just
a heart ripping beautiful film about
life like it has a couple of you know
good lines but or it was
funny but in a it's in a very gentle
it's not i wouldn't really call it a
comedy in except in the broadest sense
of like
comedy it's not it's not a heavy movie
it's not a super dramatic movie even
though it sort of could have been given
its subject matter and jason that's
that's his specialty he's amazing at
those kinds of movies and so when when
it was like
you know he makes movies about people
trying to figure out life what the hell
this business does he have to do making
like a wacky let's shoot ghostbusters
with proton packs and what i love is
that he clearly adapted to like he he
onboarded a lot of his father's
sensibility uh in making it you know as
sort of there there is plenty of
ghostbusters-y like silliness uh that
that the first movie had a lot of heart
and it was about like some guys starting
up a business and
but not like his not like jason
reitman's movies though like
why aren't they different
movies oh you have to see up in the air
it's unbelievable masterpiece but but
like here's my point oh no i haven't
seen it i have seen this thanks for
smoking and actually thank you for
smoking is probably the most overt
comedy of hit because it's so over the
top and it's ludicrousness of like this
guy who's the tobacco lobbyist but the
point i was gonna make and what i loved
is that the movie has it silly like i
remember the first time i saw in the
trailer you see like paul rudd looking
at all the little mini oh i've stayed
marshmallow man and all those like i i
have this reaction of like
you know that's so hard for me to square
with what i expect from a jason wright
movie and what i love is that it
actually is exactly
the it is exactly
from my point of view the
the the ghostbusters that jason son of
ivan would make for the simple reason
that the whole premise
is
um the estranged granddaughter of
of deceased egon spangler has to go
you know inherit his abandoned farm in
the middle of nowhere and they they
moved to this place to clean it up
because incidentally she's broke and
she's nev she's barely knew her father
you know this so-called famous
world-saving ghostbusters who no one's
heard from for a long time and became
this total recluse and she she hates him
and it's like the whole movie you're
right if you take this possibility some
subtext
oh it does feel that way because like
there is there's totally commentary on
like
you know dad didn't love me he was too
busy working
i was like i really i wonder if this is
a movie of jason saying dad i i didn't
get to know you during my childhood
because you were too busy being a
hollywood icon but this movie is my
i love you and i forgive you uh because
look what you embolden like what you
enabled the career in life for me to
have so supposedly i have no idea total
conjecture i've
to him the whole time and was telling
him like this isn't good enough yeah
apparently like he was there just being
like this isn't good enough what are you
doing you don't know what you're doing i
mean they've done certainly a lot of
press together in the aftermath so it
clearly didn't lead to
no i think it was okay but
i'm always like man my parents just are
so great they're like everything you do
is incredible yeah look at you guys
none of that that's the subtext of this
podcast is alana has wonderful i do have
really good parents i always feel kind
of guilty about how supportive my
parents are but yeah i i did wonder even
watching it if that subtext was there
and you are right that
if you remove the ghostbusters from that
plot that actually
is
is it's in line
and i loved that i love that it's it's
like this move i just it's one of those
that as i was driving home and i was
sort of thinking about it i was angela
and i went on we were talking about it
and it was like the more i talked about
it the more i realized man i really this
is every this is everything that i would
want from
this movie you know like again there's a
few little things i can i can quibble
with but and and obviously you know
there's a few spoilery things that i
won't say but but broadly speaking i was
and and also i gotta give
um
love to my
friend and colleague rob simonson
who had the unenviable task of figuring
out how to score a movie like this when
the original is such an iconic
score by one of the legendary composers
of all time elmer bernstein you know who
famously would get pigeonholed in
different genres 10 years at a time so
like he did you know the man with the
golden arm in the 50s and wrote this
very noteworthy jazz score and then was
like the guy for i was going to say
really
quite jazzy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's very it's very like almost 50s
horror sci and and rob did such a good
job great of mixing the the
comedic sort of the old and the new and
horror into a skull uh there's almost
nobody and there's almost no q in that
whole score that isn't somehow infused
with elmer bernstein like there's almost
every even the most seemingly nothing
cues where you think oh he probably just
wrote some little simple thing for this
it's actually him riffing on a simple
corollary moment in the first and again
it's not i don't it doesn't read as
nostalgia it reads as homage and
continuation and maybe that's just maybe
it's like if i like it it's that and if
i don't like it i call it nostalgia and
maybe i'm just biased i can acknowledge
that i may not have the most precise
metrics here but it really did feel like
he absorbed the heart and soul of it to
such a um
uh sort of perfect degree and and and
carry that torch forward and it's not an
easy task
um totally but yeah it's also it's not
easy anyway like when i saw ghostbusters
uh again i saw it as an adult
i thought it was perfect i was like oh
it is i expected this movie to be
one of those movies that like people
liked when they were kids that they like
just continued to be fond of and maybe
it was a bit funny like star wars kinda
i'm sorry i just like to poke the bear
there's the comments
sorry but like that was pure masochism
to me that's that's to me masters of the
universe is what you just described it's
one of those that on reevaluation it
doesn't it doesn't work fair yeah and i
mean there are also bad star wars but um
ghostbusters i was like which one's a
lot but we don't need to get into that
i was like ghostbusters i was like oh
this is just a [ __ ] perfect film
it's like back to the future where you
go back and you watch it and you go
there's literally nothing there's always
nothing wrong with change nothing wrong
with it and i feel like i'm like i
always find something that i'm like i
didn't love that though that was a bit
and very unformulaic as well it's a tiny
bit rapey
that's it though ghostbusters there's a
little bit of oh i forgot that scene
consent issues but
yeah even that i was all right with i
can't even think of the scene you're
talking about it are you talking about
like the key master stuff
um yeah doesn't he like make out with
someone without her knowing or tries to
when she's not herself
yeah there's a bit of bill murray creepy
yeah not the bill murray's creepy i've
yeah no i think you i feel like you're
remembering it back isn't it he might be
remembering about that she's possessed
as the uh as the like it's the
gatekeeper in the keymaster and but i
think he still tries to hit on a
well he starts to and then he realizes
she's actually not herself and he tries
to put her to bed and like leave her and
and say like okay we this is not okay
he's definitely doesn't take advantage
of it
but i think he maybe gets close i don't
remember there's a couple of like
it was like there were like there's like
a couple of little beats austin where
it's like like a little knowingly like
oh i i'm being a gentleman here but
crikey she looks attractive right
there's a few just a few looks to camera
that are like comedy of the era that of
the year would have been fine but again
rewatch it to see it in my mind it was
always very above board because it's
like it's because he doesn't realize at
first the extent of the situation and
then and just thinks maybe she's being
weird and then it's kind of like no i
feel like i remember something when like
one of them was in bed specifically that
i was like oh but again
it wasn't enough that i
i'm not thinking it's a perfect film
like i was like this movie is [ __ ]
incredible uh whereas yeah i mean after
life
i could definitely dig to find more
issues with and i imagine most of the
criticism is
of like you said they um force awakens
it a little bit it it really is a rehash
but when i go to feel like they're
trying to reboot it like does it feel
like it's setting up a franchise is it
that kind of movie where there is for
sure another one in the making
right okay i know i i will say one of my
favorite one of the perfect little
glimpses of why the first one is perfect
is i've always loved
that
um
there's always kind of multiple layers
of humor happening in most scenes like
there's sort of funny things that are
you know kind of um
uh
the obvious forward-facing thing and
then subtle and
you know there's a million good examples
but my single favorite
is at the end after the
uh stay puft marshmallow man has
exploded and you don't know the outcome
and you see everybody kind of emerging
out of the rubble and you see the
ghostbusters kind of getting themselves
up and they're completely covered head
to toe in marshmallow and they convene
in the center and bill murray just comes
walking in from off-screen completely
clean and they never acknowledge it they
don't explain like how did he avoid all
and it's just like of course he would he
just somehow wasn't posed and it's
everyone's like are you okay i'm fine
and it's just they just move on and that
even when i just like i'll be like in
traffic and that image will pop into my
head
yeah i get that
and it's full of that kind of thing
where you can't
i just always wonder from a
screenwriting standpoint
how to how they
hit on the like what which of those were
discoveries made while shooting what was
gonna say is i feel like
some of those or somebody on set was
like
this could be funny you're like because
i mean that movie is actually i don't
i'm gonna look this up i think there's
an anecdote that that was literally
because bill murray was like i'm not
gonna cover myself in shaving foam i
think i genuinely i think that was it
could be and it's [ __ ] hilarious if
that like if so then brilliant use of it
to do a joke as you say yeah that's kind
of like the indiana jones shooting the
sword wielder guy just because he
literally couldn't shoot for more than
10 seconds at a time before diarrhea
running to the toilet
so like they made an iconic bit using
what they had to work with it could be
one of those i don't know but i but to
me the movie is just a wash and another
one incredible oh here we go
so yes uh
bill murray uh refused to be covered in
much so he's got a little bit on him but
he was like i don't want all of that on
me whereas down acro i thought it was
the funniest thing ever so is noticeably
covered in about twice as much as every
other character it's literally covering
everything except his eyes yeah that's
really good yeah it's like apparently it
was a a very personal uh decision which
i respect that's a respectful direction
especially because it came out being
funny that way and it and it did that is
that is awesome and it's very in line
with the rest of bill murray like his
character it feels somehow very
aligned with all of the other character
moments throughout the movie you know
like it feels like a
fenceman thing that's like in the sense
wouldn't get you get the sense that like
they knew how to use well because it was
a bunch of snl alumni right so they were
all kind of oh we knew each other and
all knew kind of what would what would
what would work i
don't feel like afterlife
is
as
candidly funny
um as the original ghostbusters but it's
still like i still laughed out loud and
i feel like i rarely do that in a cinema
where i actually like it's not just like
a huh it's like an actual project that
was my concern watching the trailer like
it's again like being the voice of
ignorance um like i from watching the
trailer genuinely got the impression it
was like going to be very kind of
superhero movie-esque kind of like
action fair rather than like a
straight-up comedy because i think that
first trailer was very kind of
inspirational music i think yeah
and that's all that's what's coming
across from what you're saying that's
actually you guys have actually sold me
on the movie i think the trailers yeah i
i definitely also laughed the uh
the uh kid podcast was for me the most
consistently funny uh in the movie i
found because there was a kid called
pogba he called himself podcast and he's
always like narrating because he has a
podcast yeah yeah and
yeah
no he's great he's great he was he was
yeah he was and i felt like they they
used him well that he didn't it it
it always runs the risk of becoming like
a stick that you're like okay you know
we need his obligatory
thing and it kind of walked to the edge
of that for me a little bit but there
was another another
little bit that's like again i laughed
out loud was you know there's this
uh
keymaster thing in the original where
sigourney weaver is transformed into
this like glistening flowing dress and
kind of like the iconic jeff goldblum
open shirt jurassic park thing there's
this pose of her like lying there with
her leg propped up and there's a moment
where they recreate that with paul rudd
and that killed me i yeah as soon as i
saw him he pulled it off though
oh yeah seeing him pose as sigourney
weaver
i was like see that's that's a love
that's like them going okay how do we if
you want to try to make the audience
remember things do something with it
that's not just lazily recreating it and
that was an example where i know i
actually laughed
well and the audience wants to enjoy
this independently funny that kind of
thing is funny whether you've seen it or
not yeah it's true you could actually
have no idea that that was a reference
original and it's just to see him all
seductively posed it was very yeah he
was great also the the um the actress
who played the mother i didn't i didn't
know who she was but i also thought she
was fantastic the the little girl who's
the lead
also wonderful finn wolfhard most people
would know from stranger things i mean i
think the holocaust was was really yeah
the girl
especially um i can't remember her name
i looked it up and i've already
forgotten her name is it very stranger
thingsie in tone because that's i think
that's the other thing that the trailer
definitely was trying to imply i did see
some criticism um
like when i vaguely looked it up where i
saw somebody say that but
i didn't feel like it was stranger
thingsie so is it just people seeing
kids on an adventure and going strange
yeah but then why aren't they saying it
you know
it um
well i remember when it came out they
said oh it's a bit strange of things
it's like i think you've got your
it's like when that's
saying that the best one was when i saw
someone someone saying that um
that avatar had ripped off halo in terms
of its spaceship design and it's like no
halo ripped off aliens from jim cameron
i said when we were talking about dune i
had this weird thing with dune after
reading the wheel of time series where i
was like this is just wheel of time but
obviously because dude came first
it was like how dare you rehash this
storyline of these 15 [ __ ] books i
read but no i don't feel like it feels
stranger thingsy because
stranger things and it
to me feel like
kids teaming up to to this little friend
group with their little internal drama
teaming up to
take on a bad guy and they're brave and
the kids are saving the day this feels a
lot more again like ghostbusters except
that they are just children which is
that this ragtag group kind of ends up
together and is like uh
i guess we have to figure this out i
don't know and everything just like kind
of breaks and they're just like
different characters solving a problem
it's less like heroic then i feel like a
stranger things or an it
that's what that's cool because that was
that yeah i don't i don't want my
ghostbusters to be heroes i mean it is
tasty
i mean even the screenshot you have in
the background was like an example of
you know them trying to sort of step up
to the but they mess it up every step of
the way true i agree to its credit like
it's it's not also honestly happening
they're meant to be schmoes they're
meant to be kind of slightly [ __ ] yeah
they are yeah and so is their tech which
is like i love they're still using
outdated tech
so they like everything's broken and
they don't know what they're doing or
how to use it and i feel like that
worked really well
yeah yeah just so much
you've sold me i just i don't know
though because like what again when i
saw the so the it's the rotten tomatoes
is 63
the audience score is 95
and it's just so surprising to me
because i had no idea what their reviews
were obviously came out on friday it's
doing really well at the box office um
but i've not really seen impressions and
but ron tomorrow's is a terrible again
like getting back to the statistics a
terrible way of yes of handling
every time that i have to explain it to
someone they're like does that mean six
out of ten i'm like no it means 63
percent of people thought it was good
it's if you're only scaling if your
scale is binary of [ __ ] or good then
you're gonna get so much variance there
but i mean there are literal scores of
fives and sixes i think ign gave it a
ten out of ten but there are um it
doesn't deserve a ten out of ten either
no i don't think so either but i mean
that's something that's really the
citizen kane of ghostbusters
some of these reviews it's so funny when
you read the the top critic expert
excerpts from ghostbusters or any really
review on on rotten tomatoes like what
do you what are these people trying to
say this is from mark feeney from the
boston globe it has its moments but they
don't make up for a general
flat-footedness and tendency to wobble
do you say the movie is flat-footed
yes and it's just as a tendency of
wobbling let me tell you okay as
somebody who did journalism for a long
time
your job is to make things as
understandable as possible what the [ __ ]
are you trying to say in defense of that
review that i have no interest in like
it like presumably the rest of the
review would give you that
why would your leading line not be
clearer the next one directly below that
so often on raw tomatoes it's not the
lead and that's the interesting thing on
raw tomatoes often it's just a quote and
maybe rotten tomatoes picks it rather
than the reviewer
oh they definitely do okay that actually
excuses it the next one underneath is
from hannah strong from little white
lies and it says haunting but not in the
good way
what does that mean that's someone who
that's someone who had the line
but then had to still have the review
together did you find that did you find
it scary what are you trying to do i'm
assuming what she means is that it's
like overburdened by its connection to
the previous film oh she's definitely
being cute oh yeah oh like haunted by it
is haunted by those films in a way that
doesn't do its service that's my guess
about what hannah how do you forgive me
the next negative one is from aaron new
worth from we live entertainment while
there's a very nice core idea there's a
lot of missing texture that ultimately
didn't make boston feel too good this
time around
see again though having fun right they
are having these things
the articles though these are like these
are like conclusions on runtimes i think
they often just grab a conclusion or
whatever
yeah i mean
yeah we don't need to do it okay
i guess so there is one here that says
afterlife eventually reduces to the
cheap appeals of nostalgia pandering um
again i'm not surprised that some people
feel that way i think it it's not hard
to make that case i did not feel that
way it's super interesting austin you
didn't feel that way
um
i know a lot of ghostbusters fans who
didn't but
it's seeing that i don't have the
nostalgia so i very much i think it was
soldier
last time
yeah it was similar to it reminded me of
uh lower decks which is like the
animated star trek show that came out
which was genuinely like my favorite
star trek in years like genuinely really
good but all the early stuff for that
implied it was going to be kind of a
nostalgia reference heavy thing i think
that's something that definitely seems
like a trend that if you're making a
franchise installment selling nostalgia
with a trailer
they must have done some metrics that
must be the thing that they think is
going to get people in in theaters
regardless of what the actual reality of
the thing is once you say that's the way
i think it does happen
a he-man
show i think it is just called mustard
universe that's the issue with that one
is
the he-man is almost not in the first
half of the season whatsoever but the
trailer is almost entirely human
and people were mad about the lack of
he-man and i feel like they maybe
wouldn't have been because tila is still
a cool character but when you market it
with that expectation like
yeah people get pissed off um but
i think that's an interesting conundrum
though like because if he-man was the
draw of the original
um
you know you want to make sure you get
you capture that audience and just hope
they're going to give you a chance to
realize like it's not quite
we're not rehashing the original series
that's true
this split season thing that a lot of
shows do now where it's like like i
assume they all find him in the second
half of the season and it feels like
this triumphant appearance well he is
released in one go that would give you
the show
but i yeah it's complicated but i i do
expect that he will be
back in the second half you would think
that your he-man show would end with
hero he man looking awesome but yeah
that split maybe has caused a weird it's
happening with a few shows especially if
you don't write for that like it's
entirely possible right exactly the team
may well have not known that's what was
coming yeah um but my thing with with
ghostbusters afterlife is like
you know anyone who doesn't like it i
never want to
say someone's wrong because i don't
agree with it i'm at a point with this
movie where i would love to talk to
somebody who doesn't like it or maybe i
should just read some of these reviews
to like get the perspective because i
was so surprised um
and this one
i'm not making fun of this i genuinely
don't know what this is referring to
there's a reference here that i don't
understand this is ian simmons kicking
the seat for a movie that took decades
to put together afterlife plays like the
equally tired the house with a clock in
its walls with ghostbusters branding
sloppily applied to a shoot the first
draft sensibility
that's a jack black movie yeah it's eli
ross book i think
yes that's right
i didn't see it differently strange
reference but it took decades to make it
did and it was also finished
two years ago but they wanted to release
it after covert so it got delayed
so people would go to the cinema well
fortunately covid's been absolutely and
it's gone hundred percent gone
no lasting impact related to that i saw
an article um that said
um that variety basically claimed
that
the new james bond
is a
despite a 700 million dollar plus global
box office return
they claim is still 100 million shy of
breaking even and it's the highest
earning covet era film so far to date
wow um i still haven't seen it i've been
i've been dying to but i just haven't
made it i really enjoyed it
yeah i've i've only heard universal
praise i've not heard a single person
didn't say it's it's anything they had
some interesting financial stuff right
because the sponsorship side of it i
don't
um what was the vehicle well because all
that stuff was in there but because the
film but because the film was delayed
all the products their product placed
were
came out and they were you know we've
now moved on so i think there was some i
don't know how far how deeply they had
extra issues with like sponsors but the
sponsors were like well you're selling a
watch that came out two years ago so we
don't want to pay all the omega yes
james bond has forever been subsidized
by that that's how that's how bond
always has so much expense and value in
it is because they literally subsidize
it with product placement to an extent
that most films do but james bond that
that character has such cachet that they
can get ridiculous amounts of product
placement but the product placement
would have that like that why would that
hold back their profitability on the
tail end like it's not
it is it's not the no no it's the it
would it wouldn't hold back their
profitability but sorry it wouldn't hold
back their earnings but it would lower
their profits
seamaster initial product cost it has
been sold out for ages though so like i
don't know how you quantify that in any
case it's probably regardless of if they
profit or not wouldn't change their
gross but it would change their net ost
well they would have broken a contract
and thus omega is going to be like you
broke the contract though so give us
money because that's how businesses work
i don't know
we're withholding money or taking we
want a refund of our money yeah for the
record it was essentially a rumor and
mgm put out a statement saying um
uh that's a bunch of [ __ ] and it's
been very good for us and we're
extremely happy with it um like it out
it outsold the fast and the furious
movie which was it's done incredibly
internationally
domestically someone
some anonymous source was quoted by
variety saying that the movie was going
to lose 100 million dollars despite
earning
721 million and mgm came out and said
well thank you unnamed source but we can
tell you on behalf of the studio that
we're very happy with the results and it
has definitely not lost
i could see it being true though in
terms of like especially with if you
think about how many times they had to
reboot their marketing process like that
film was
heavily marketed for its initial like to
the extent that like daniel craig was on
because he was right at the start of the
pandemic right daniel craig was like on
snl the week it was i mean yeah they
released they released the billy eilish
uh theme song
uh
uh ahead of the movie's release and then
as a single yeah and then she won a
grammy for best song for visual media at
last year's grammy and the movie came
out fully a year after a while which i
think is the only time
you know the classic thing of like the
the cliche is a movie the amount of
money a movie actually costs is the
budget of the movie then you double it
for all the marketing spend if you think
about like they had to basically do two
rounds of marketing at least on this and
then some stuff in between it could be
you might it might well have like them
it might not been the movie's production
budget but like the marketing alone
rebooting that marketing a couple of
times could genuinely have like courses
it says
this is from business insider they say
that it costs 250 million to produce
and
that the opening weekend was just over
84 million and they expected it to be
over 100 million but so let's take those
numbers so 250 to make
750 made worldwide so far because i
literally just watched again i watched
way too much analysis stuff i watched
like something about the box office
moneybags mike you know what i'm saying
i just really like numbers yeah you love
capitals dude i get it i love cat i love
capitalism know your enemy alana no your
enemy um also anyone listening who uh
like it is also its numbers watch the
defunct land hour and 40 minute
documentary the defunct land made on the
queueing system at disney world it's
genuinely amazing um the uh
just leave it really good if you're a
nerd it's amazing it's like literally
about traffic flow within theme parks
it's it's cool it's lovely um anyway
back to this like if if it's made 750
worldwide and it costs 250 to produce
common sense kind of the the wisdom of
the standard wisdom is that you double
it so it's 500 million it costs to make
and market
if they did have to reboot their
marketing
and i'm right there like they would have
and probably they didn't but let's say
they did put in like double the
marketing because of this then that does
bring them up to 750 which means they
are basically just about to break even
which would put them quite close to that
line although the claim was that at 720
they're a hundred million shy still so
there's definitely some money
unaccounted for even with there'd be
at 720 by what i'm saying like it would
be close
either way
apropos nothing in shifting gears since
i mentioned billy eilish uh
winning a grammy for uh
you know the original song for motion
for visual media category last year
today this morning
they announced the grammy the new round
of grammy nominees
and
um
i i this is a thing i was actually i was
going to bring up and ask you guys about
where we're pretty much at time but i'm
just i i have to put out there i have to
put a shout out because i'm very proud
of my friend there's this girl i've been
kind of um on again off again sort of
mentoring is probably too strong a word
but being an ear to give advice for
she's a young uh the wind beneath her
wings no no she needs absolutely none
from anybody she's a she is a true
wunderkind um you know by age 19 i think
had performed piano on ellen like seven
or eight times and and she's you know
quincy jones uh was mentoring her as a
young kid and her name is emily bear she
uh last year um uh she and a friend
started writing songs for fun on
instagram and tick tock
under the premise of what if bridgeton
was a musical and it went so viral like
literally in the many tens of millions
of hits uh maybe even you know hundreds
of millions that they that they ended up
essentially producing it as a proper
record and this morning got grammy
nominated as best musical theater
alongside like steven schwartz and les
mis revivals oh that's amazing
she's like 20 and i think her
her cohort abigail barlow is i think
like 21. wow um and they performed bits
of it from at the kennedy center earlier
this year and like they've had this just
outrageous they must have gone to like
netflix and got the right that's my
thing is that legal release that
commercially they don't i don't think
they're actually using the permission i
don't think netflix is smart they're
going to i don't think they're using
anything that's actually copy written
because it's it is all i
isn't
i mean i don't know how the specifics of
this particular aspect of it works
because they are referencing the story
and characters but it's not referencing
they don't use any like artwork for the
album cover is the two of them the
parody could potentially save them
but that said of course netflix even
without yankovic had to get the rights
so as long as they're not no no
cover does not require rights out weird
al has never yanked vic got the rights
for most of the songs he did it's not
needed it's absolutely
what's called a compulsory license says
that if you were making a call it might
have been like a nicety then maybe he
may have yeah
he doesn't need to get licenses for
songs wait really if you're making your
own version of a song if you're doing a
cover
you the artist the copyright holder an
intellectual property owner cannot stop
you
um they do on youtube
well they can't stop you from
commercially releasing them you do have
to you have to you have to yeah you do
have to pay a lot of royalty but you
they cannot but they can't stop you they
cannot so if i was uh if i was if i was
a pop star and then different pop star
that i hated wanted to cover my song i
couldn't stop them correct wow um i know
that's interesting it's what's yeah it's
it's it's uh you just have to get what's
called a compulsory uh license and and
that's why that's why
uh now there are you know there are
right and wrong ways to find it
it says with weird al it says al does
get permission from the original writers
of the songs that he parodies but while
the law supports his ability to parry
without permission he feels it's
important to maintain the relationships
that he's built with artists and writers
over the years so it's not required it's
respectful no way that's cool point
being though on this netflix uh
richardson thing they definitely did get
the attention uh because it went so
viral they definitely got the attention
and like they oh if you're on netflix
you throw every bit of support you can
and they did they you know the cast i
was tweeting about it even and stuff i
think and and like they definitely got a
lot of love but i was just so
um insanely happy for her uh to to have
this happen but it also i was talking to
a friend about it a couple hours ago and
it made me realize
it might be the most extreme example of
success of something that is effectively
fan art uh and it made me wonder what
would be an example of
fan art that spun off into its own fully
legit thing first thought i had was
league of legends
yeah
but shades of grey is like the absolute
light the biggest one incredible massive
one yeah made the most money that was
based on twilight if you didn't know
oh really i didn't know that it was from
it was a fanfiction toilet
i've never known that yeah
um that's so funny oh that probably
straight away goes too but because my my
brain first went to like counter-strike
in league of legends which were
effectively community mods on existing
games that grew into a billion dollars
forgotten city um you could make a
similar case for forgotten city came out
this year um it was originally just a
skyrim mod
fortnite was basically saved by
that's different
an uged let's say an ode to a different
game yeah but that's different that
that's that no we don't know what do i
give you odes shall we say are there's
plenty examples of of odds
but i think something that's explicitly
like this was it's literally called the
unofficial bridgerton musical is the
name of the album that's so cool well
there's a quote there's quite a few
speculative musicals on there's quite a
few musicals that are based on like
existing ip that were initially made
without permission and then pitched
basically once they were completed
that's that's been an arc for quite a
few musicals right am i right saying
that yeah yeah i mean i have a friend i
don't know if i'm allowed to say this
publicly but i have a friend who did a
very popular tv show
and
um thought it could be interesting as a
musical so he started writing it to then
go and pitch
to the studio and say like okay i've
written a few songs are you willing to
kind of produce this and like see it
through um so like that i know that
he undertook that to
you know and probably did so knowing
that there's some precedent for it but
but this was purely which i guess any
pitch for an ip is fan fiction until you
know god of war
but this was never supposed to be
this was never going to be commercial
this was just these two young girls who
were very cool
and they wrote the songs live on
instagram they would literally turn on
instagram live and sit and like
brainstorm and she would play piano and
they would send it underneath the entire
creative process which to me is like i
want to vomit thinking about that like
that's that the idea of turning on a
camera while i work is unfathomable to
me and but yeah it made me think you
know i i wonder if
because because counter-strike people
would 100 watch that by the way austin
if you put up a video that was you
basically like pottering around figuring
something out they would want to i'm
streaming while doing invoices before
because the board is [ __ ]
talk to me while i do these [ __ ]
numbers to me
creating
is a fundamentally different
muscle from
uh performing and if someone is anywhere
even within earshot my brain goes you're
performing right now and creativity
which is a which is about curiosity and
is about exploring and is about failing
i basically
mitigate
the ability to fail because i now am
performing you know it's like if i'm on
stage i'm just saying i don't ever
stream any of my work because for the
exact reason i would feel
so put upon by that by their eyeballs
yeah other the best case scenario is
i'll make something very safe and very
generic because i'm exactly yeah like i
don't do something just to show off
yeah
i i yeah i've had friends my friend andy
schatz
he'll go
code on twitch and stuff and just like
actively like
open the door while he's working on a
game and and and uh we've talked about
that before with regard to music and i'm
like not a chance to do that with
writing because then i would be
distracted from the writing
like i write best when i'm not doing
anything other than just putting words
on a page but um i have done editing
streaming complete isolation when i'm
writing yeah i can't even have anything
no i can't even use my phone otherwise i
just won't do it
um i'm right now i'm a week away from my
i'm on a week like basic sabbatical from
my team just to write some stuff i've
seen you tweeting though mike i've seen
your tweets you've been tweeting about
it
you gotta you gotta cut that [ __ ] out if
you wanna get writing
that's how it works i have written i if
i told you how many words i've written
in the last two days you would be okay
i'm gonna throw one last uh
random curveball but uh
epic acquired harmonics today did you
see i saw that
that uh uh with the the conjecture being
that uh it's about expanding the whole
virtual concert thing of fortnite like
fuser is harmonics
yeah right
it is yeah yeah yeah um i'm like rock
band yeah i mean the rock band pod is
more exciting to me because like i've i
still frequently
play rock band guitar hero
um with two sets of friends who have
like the full kits and it's [ __ ]
awesome like having those parties and
still playing those is awesome um so
then potentially bringing those back and
maybe figuring out ways to like make
them
internet
safe
um is super exciting but i feel like
yeah fuse uh fuser wasn't particularly
successful even though it's a really
interesting concept to me it is cool
right it's right in the wheelhouse of
the stuff that interests me there's a
lot of just music nerds over there like
it's it's not i think people think of
them as a studio that just makes games
about music but like the people who work
there are
they're basically everyone who works
there is a musician it's ridiculous so
so it's also just from a hiring point of
view if if epic have identified music as
something that they want to do more with
just generally it would make a lot of
sense it's called an aqua hire basically
like acquiring company just to hire all
the people who work there like i could
see even if it's not a direct like we
are going to put this team on to doing
something with it
might just be like we just want all that
music talent in the house it is it is
interesting i i feel like um yeah
obviously they had those those full
concerts inside of um fortnite and
travis scott was the last one maybe i
don't remember um which looked very cool
from what i saw of them and i i think
that fortnight as a platform probably
doesn't get the respect that i feel like
it deserves you know like fortnite is
memed to hell
um
it's the kids game right now but what
fortnite does as a platform
is really [ __ ] cool
plus that that travis scott concert
i mean you're talking about
tens of millions of simultaneous viewers
i mean like as a as a concept for you
get to interact
yeah like it's a wild
new frontier of like it definitely made
the entire music industry go
maybe we've there's a new frontier for
concert giving
that we've
wildly over because the music industry
is perpetually on live support going you
know
how do we reclaim our former glory days
where we used to be kind of a
financially relevant part of the the
entertainment economy you know now just
so heavily dwarfed by
uh film tv and video games um that games
suddenly offered this window of like you
know we can kind of maybe do a cool
thing together well throughout the
pandemic there are a lot of artists who
are advertising like they're doing a
live show on twitch and i would never
buy any of those because i know what
that looks like it is people in a room
playing instruments with bad audio
quality what the fortnite concerts offer
and that there are like vr um djing
games and even fuse it to an extent
though i'd say it's a little bit less
cool is
you don't know what to expect from what
you're going to see out of travis scott
right hopefully people don't die related
um at a travis scott fortnight concert
you know like you don't know what
they're going to do what you are going
to be able to do like the fact that
gameplay can intertwine with that i
think is
is very exciting like that's super cool
um it's also a great opportunity for
musicians to make some money as well yes
like if you look at how the streaming
platforms have kind of muscled them out
like
i wonder how that works on fortnight is
isn't fortnite free to play
well
i don't know i think we'll pay
ethical pay for ethical pay oh yeah oh
yeah they make micro transaction money
or like micro trans and also like you
know buying a hat with a logo on it or
something well i think you can probably
but
travis scott's definitely i mean he's
fine actually he's i mean he's doing
okay financially i wouldn't miss
travis scott brandon so oh my god his
shoes go for thousands
that's wild
yeah but that's the thing is that's what
to be us to be a financially successful
musician these days you you need a shoe
yeah which is you know do you i i
depending on what you define as
financially successful i'm a musician
and i don't have a shoe oh no no i made
it i made it i made a declarative
statement i'm sorry have you thought
about it though i'd wear one oh no for
the record
for the record i very rarely wear shoes
god that uh is so dirty no is it no it's
not what's dirty about myself oh it's
okay it's just yellowed at the top
because of the color oh yellow the toast
more proud of the toast that's the brand
there's gold tip what's wrong with you
you got to get on this boat is it a
specific sock that's it's called gold
tip
i don't know why they're just
comfortable i'm i'm old-fashioned i have
socks that one color i i've not i've not
achieved no yes
obviously there are lots of ways of
being successful but like i know a lot
of people who work in the kind of
on the kind of uh
essentially outside of soundtracks
essentially working in
where they're basically making music to
put it on spotify and those those people
are struggling financially because
there's not much
yeah it's funny
you have to have ancillary product where
you have to basically you have to you
have to sell your music that's what i
was gonna like awesome to a company or
you make you make money as a musician
from
tours and merch right like i feel like
that's what i've always been told is
musicians make money from two isn't
merch
uh these days that's where the bulk of
the money would come from but that's
what i'm saying
streaming and all that
is the only reason they decry it like
the huge like the metallicas of the
world the only reason they would decry
uh spotify and such is because it makes
them so much less than the glory days of
90s cds because in those days you go to
best buy and you pay like 21 for a
40 minute
10 track album and they and you know and
it's the only way to consume music you
want one song like look at james horner
the platinum soundtrack sold 11 million
copies because everybody so james horner
made something like 30 million dollars
plus
from an album where everybody wanted the
celine dion song and didn't notice the
hour of orchestral film music that came
before it and
and those days are done so i it's funny
i i remember bill maher did a monologue
about this right but new people but
sorry new people are also like not
making any money on but but that doesn't
matter
i've never understood but that they
like where do you so so let's use you
like am i right assuming most of the
use you most of the money you make
presumably is from
the companies paying you to do
soundtracks from and then from live and
merch right it's you're you're saying i
don't really really
final so yeah sure spotify doesn't move
the needle much for you i'm assuming in
terms of the money you're making i can
pay my rent from spotify uh uh like
that's good i yeah
that's that's high that's higher than i
was expecting yeah i mean it's it's i'm
very lucky because you know if it like
you know but the the absolute banner
saga and journey
um it's it's
you know
several million streams per month uh
yeah and like and that's what it though
okay so that's that adds up to you so
that's my point is just to do like seven
seven million streams a month pays your
rent well it's not seven it's less than
that but it's it's it's a couple uh
and but point is it's not it i don't it
kind of just so pays the like it's like
the bills are covered but i couldn't
really live on it but the point is
i'm also a small fish compared to a lot
of folks out there um and uh but they're
smaller fish right there of course but
that this is why i've always found this
line of reasoning very bizarre because
being a musician has for all of human
history been one of the most difficult
and like
unequally distributed
uh uh career planning
this is why exactly this is ex why most
parents are like if the kid goes i kind
of want to
sing they could play guitar and singer
they're like oh please anything else
because they don't want their kid
condemned to a life of destitution it
has always been and the thing is applies
to twitch streamers that's the thing now
everyone thinks you get rich it's one
percent
it's that and same it's the same in
music the so the the number of
like people
i think
there's a lot of very bad statistical
analysis going on when people say oh the
streamers have screwed everything yes
there's no question that
that the the lower barriers to entry the
sort of technological disruption has
probably brought net revenues down
although it is growing again for the
first time in 20 years because those
streaming revenues and also things like
vinyl have been actively growing in ways
that all the other like all other
physical media have been in decline it's
still smaller than it was but the reason
it was bigger before is because it was a
it was a
a sort of market bubble like the dot-com
bubble prior to its bursting because you
you wanted one song and you had to spend
20 dollars and the 90s was like a fairly
roaring economic time in general so
there was like those prices weren't the
norm they were an artificial high and
the market corrected with new technology
but the criticism of new musicians just
to i'm i'm genuinely i'm i'm basically
prodding you because it's interesting
like i just i'm interested in your your
take on this
so
the argument i've heard from from
musicians who are kind of who are
basically rocking the austin numbers
like maybe hitting a couple million a
month but it's not enough to live off of
basically their criticism isn't i should
be a millionaire like in the 90s it's
um
spotify makes much like the the the cut
the cut of what i get should be bigger
from the subscription and that is a
fundamentally different argument and yes
spotify i for me the jury is perpetually
out there it's breadcrumbs right yeah i
would make that argument with youtube as
well
the amount of money i've heard the same
argument made by youtube for sure
yeah and there have been people that say
you know it it like the way spotify's
business model works in general is
their
users subscribe i think i believe there
is a free model with ads although i
can't honestly can't remember because
i've
subscribed so long ago i don't actually
remember what the alternatives are but i
believe there is a free with like
limitations on how much you can stream
like cards and then a couple of
subscription levels yeah so um
and then so but basically let's say they
make a billion dollars uh
you know a year from their subscriber
income
you know setting aside their internal
costs staff servers blah blah blah and
there's people that would argue you know
they're like the things you always hear
like their ceo makes way too much money
blah blah blah whatever setting all that
aside
if you're just looking about looking at
what's getting paid out to the artists
into the record labels into all of that
um
it basically just says okay here's the
pot of money we made and now we're gonna
distribute this based on
um like if we if we made let's say the
net revenue uh
after we subtracted our
cost is 800 million
uh
and now we just basically divide it up
based on how many total streams and how
many of those total streams were each
individual artist like it's more or less
a straightforward conversion that yields
a
stream
like a dollars which is some like you
know 100 millionth of a penny but some
streams like how many dollars per stream
does that end up yielding and and a
complaint that i've heard that i think
is a valid criticism is
you know if i pay 10 bucks a month to
spotify and like
most of my money is going to go to the
taylor swifts and adele and whoever is
sort of earning the most but i never
listened to them personally can't what
if i spent all of my money listening to
you know
abigail
barlow and emily bear bridgerton
musicals shouldn't the lion's share of
my ten dollars go to them
and like because i'm buying i'm using
spotify for their product not for
even though technically i have access to
the entire spotify library of hundreds
of millions of songs and i think that is
an interesting thing where you're kind
of saying rather than a general pot that
is then divided equally and whoever has
the most streams wins it's actually
catered to what are you listening to and
let's make sure that those are and i was
like honestly that would be the [ __ ]
because then it would still stratify
heavily because obviously the vast
majority of artists i mean there's
something like 60 000 songs per day that
get released on spotify it's something
yeah bananas so like yeah of course the
vast majority of those are going to have
zero income because there's just no one
hearing them but like but then and
that's really and that's fair to be
clear i don't think i don't think many
musicians are complaining that like if i
upload something to spotify and it gets
10 listens i should be rich like i don't
think that's i think it's i think it's
more the stuff you the complexity of
what you're talking about it's also
terrifying like to those of us
especially in games right where games
right now
people still willing to pay for um we'll
see how that lasts right like that's the
idea of like video games ending up in a
similar kind of place to a spotify or
or netflix is scary yeah um i mean to me
the the the thing that's exciting about
it is it has made the entire music
industry diy you don't need a label you
don't need i mean look at phineas and
billy eilish you know it's like in a in
a bedroom with a laptop with no fancy
equipment released you know album of the
year as as like practically teenagers i
have a friend uh his name's uh ricky
montgomery who is in a band called the
honey sticks and
um you know i've known ricky for a while
whatever and uh i just made a tick tock
recently and
discovered that
ricky is like a super popular musician
on his own outside of the honey sticks
just as ricky himself which i had no
knowledge of whatsoever because a bunch
of his songs two of them went super
viral
on tick tock um in the last 12 months to
the extent that he now has millions of
listens on spotify and that was him
outside of the band doing it himself
i believe from an apartment during covid
just
happened like super successful and and
is now signed and and independently
touring and all that which is wild it
just happened because two songs went
viral yeah see like i'm i'm i this is
why i say you know
yes of course the the
the per stream
especially from spotify is extremely low
paying and it's really really rare to
like i i do i do well and i couldn't
live on it solely like if i weren't
getting paid to write scores
you know i'd be in i'm the same with you
i i get millions of views on youtube but
i couldn't afford to live on it um
whereas yeah twitch model is probably
the one that
would be more interesting to see ported
over to musicians somehow is that most
of your funding comes from individual
subscribers subscribing to you and
that's bandcamp's whole play that that's
the bandcamp model of like you're buying
directly from the artist bandcamp offers
a patreon-esque
uh subscription
um
uh service that that you know you can
like
the thing is as was pointed out by a
great independent
musician
cellist named zoe keating the big
difference with all these tools which
are really wonderful they put so much
power you're no longer being gate kept
by record labels you can do anything you
want and if it goes viral and all that
like yes it's still low probability it's
still random but there aren't suits
blocking you the way they're used to
which is why i think it's better than
the 90s by a hundred fold there aren't
you don't have to go to expensive
retailers there's so many ways to
discover and share your art and to me
it's very it's awesome we get more
variety that way too
that's great but it is it is awesome uh
i will acknowledge um
um that uh implicit in that as zoe
keating
said is that
because it's
it's like it made it more doable but
also slightly
sort of blue collar in a way and you
essentially have to constantly make and
release new music forever uh like
rarely will you like to a ridiculous
extent right yeah like no musicians who
actually have to put out like a new
single every week or whatever just to
keep the algorithm happening
yeah and that that is where it is i'm
sat here in my in in the game side like
where that's you know
and and a reasonably successful indie
like myself can have a team and can be
you know a viable business
and it's terrifying the idea that this
could one day be similar that we would
basically have to
you know bootstrap everything with small
teams and
i mean it already is stratified to that
degree that there are really small teams
and then there are really huge teams and
there aren't lots of mid-sized teams
because like we talked about last time
you can
you know you can you can justify a
million dollar budget and you can
justify a hundred million dollar budget
but it's really hard to justify a 30
million dollar budget or whatever but
what scares me is
is basically using your rent money to
make a game because that would be
difficult yeah if we end up in a
situation like that that's the point i'm
making is that's if if the bottom fell
out to that extent that would be yeah
but i would think it's also cheaper to
make a song it's cheaper to make an
individual song
oh and that's the question
to the end consumer
do they do is it does it feel like a
like a song like if you do my netflix
costs about the same as spotify yeah i
see what you're saying so it's an
interesting kind of how are we going to
validate the media market would value
that well yeah that's game pass like
we'll see we'll see how that goes it's
interesting